Like string on a spool, DNA can
be wrapped onto these important proteins called histones,
taking on a shape that's known as beads on a string. Here's an example of a
real electron microscopy picture taken of this DNA
beads on a string structure. Just like you
can see in the cartoon up here wrapped
around these Histome proteins is the DNA and
down here in the actual real life picture you
can see the little circular Histome proteins and their
connected by a string in between them because the
DNA is wrapped around them. And then on to the
next system, and on to the next one, and
on to the next one. This wrapping and folding,
leads to an intermediate form of organized DNA called
the 30 nanometer fiber and its name as you can
imagine, based on its size. The width of this
is actually about 30 nanometers. . Now that's still
small obviously Now the folding doesn't stop here. The
30nm fiber will actually start folding on itself here
in a minute, and that's what organizes into the
really big structure that we're used to seeing, called
a chromosome. So another way of looking at this
is our double-stranded DNA here, in our most zoomed-in picture.
Is actually wrapped around these histone
proteins in the 30 nanometer fiber structure.
We actually call the combination of DNA wrapped around histones, we call that
chromatin. And then chromatin is organized
into structures called chromosomes. Chromosomes are actually
organized chromatin, and you have multiple
chromosomes in the cells in your body.